jamais l'art abstrait qui sévit
maintenant n'enlève à vos intérêts ce
volume
étonnant au temps où les faux culs sans
la majorité loire à celui qui vit toute
la vérité
votre dos perd son nom avec si bonne
grâce qu'on ne peut s'empêcher de lui
donner raison
que ne suive de madame
un poète le race pour dire à sa louange
un iman el blason pour dire à sa louange
un immortel blason en le voyant passer
j'en eu la chair de poule en parle d'un
homme monde et 2,8 je lui voue un culte
véritable et quand je perds au moule
atteindra 100 fini je ne pense qu'à vous
en embrassant fanni je ne pense qu'à
vous pour obtenir madame un galbe de cet
ordre vous devez torturer les gens de
votre tour donner aux couturiers bien du
fil à votre corps et vous devez crever
bateau d'armes d'atouts et vous devez
kfw brad dame là tout c'est le tube de
bordeaux qui s'en va tête passe car il
ressemble au mien comme deux gouttes
d'eau
s'il ressemble est au vote- on dirait
quand il passe c'est un joli garçon que
le duc devant nous c'est un joli garçon
que le duc de bordeaux ne fait aucun cas
des jaloux qui professe que vous avez
placé votre orgueil veux pas que vous
pourrez y mettons en somme de vos fesses
et surtout parts à 20 ne vous asseyez
part et surtout parfum ne vous asseyez
pas laisser les raconter qu'en sortant
de calèche la brise a fait voler votre
rober convient
écrite dans un coeur transpercé d'une
flèche cette expression triviale à julos
pour la vie cette expression triviale à
julos pour la vie les scellés dire
encore qu'à la cour d'angleterre faisant
la révérence au souverain ample loire
vous êtes patatras tombé à 6 à faire la
loi de la pesanteur est dure mais c'est
la loi la loi de la pesanteur est dure
mais c'est la loi
nul ne peut aujourd'hui est passée sans
voir naples à l'assaut des
chefs-d'oeuvre
ils veulent tous sourires mes ambitions
à moi sont bien plus raisonnable voire
votre académie
madame et puis mourir pour votre
académie
madame et puis mourir ne jamais l'art
abstrait qui sévit maintenant n'enlève à
vos attrait ce volume
étonnant
au temps où les faux culs sans la
majorité loire à celui qui dit toute la
vérité